6:14 morning
lefty rock back at my apartment by
action because I moved up my car 15
minutes we miscommunicated I've got a
filter if you're not dreaming big for
yourself
he's doing it for you mommy doesn't got
a chronic level come back neither like a
visible and I see with clarity hustle my
my name is Gabby Tom but I've been
telling you how accounts of equity of
Tripoli given a pedigree to being in a
fleshly faculty when the works and I'm
doing are the moving furniture heaven
gentlemen hahahaha what I married you
did you hear your brother
ear off what's up because uh how you
doing good
you guys you're way I'm I'm my awake
kind of question is that
did you hit the gym yet this morning now
that I haven't done we're gonna do that
in Canada no I'm doing that when I'm
flying in right back
I'm tonight a yeah I've stopped tonight
like original content so my ability to
communicate like things that matter to
me and then I don't know if you have
this but I have the swipe up you have it
right I mean that's you know I mean
that's a huge deal
I'm getting about 10% I'm [ __ ] 70
that's insane but I'm doing it every day
like 15 pieces so that will happen over
time but he still me up there though I
thought what the [ __ ]
exactly that being said you're still
probably going to be able to hold it be
percent hotel room how it work yeah just
two camera nerds just Cameron Turner
Cameron her Facebook camera was that
yeah-heh visual camera yeah yep yes it's
like we're like this is a picture of a
quote in Russian to 29,000 reach
thousand likes I mean like people really
the appreciation level is extremely high
and Spanish is the one I'm really kind
of like paying it like Chinese look like
the reaches because I'm just I'm only
targeting people in my fan base I'm not
running ads even this is not discovery
this is within my own ecosystem but the
share ability is so high because show me
these people have been waiting to be
able to share my content the amount of
fans you have that want to share your
content who's translating for your
individuals amazing I love that video
well that's just incredible 93% of them
like the second it happened literally
thought they were Hollywood stars
muta'ali well okay you did like I mean
they literally moved their they
literally wanted agent they literally
need to be in a movie they literally
played it different and I would tell
every one of them like this is the game
yeah yeah Alan California counted on my
bless is only 24 what a multi-million
dollar attention
that's because I'm a dawn like Kido cuz
I'm on and I got more songs in the
beetle whoa
that's a stretch yeah I guess but you
get the gist laughing at the skeptics
because I always knew I get this wish
family knowing who this new that's
finally about it quicker you come in the
game the quicker you go out it darling
really bow [ __ ] y'all ain't got no
substance
yeah I heard you little viral song some
fun dumb [ __ ] someone month your
seasonal rapper will [ __ ] the world
[ __ ] to believe it you asses don't hit
my phone and stupid [ __ ] that's not why
I gave you my to nothing you stupid
[ __ ] the lesion block why don't happen
but I want to under 10 min to fat taters
ground and in depth meanwhile I'm
swimmin in cash I was never cool y'all
I'm trying to think up now because my
train left the station but it's a very
late let's random blowing like crazy
idea we get a random lo hash that old
supply selection you know I want to walk
want to surprise hello hip walk and
surprise hello both more more more east
on you bacon to me grab you keep on a
Clio later up the rock we're go in look
at that chin question I first and he
shows shin I'm so same
they got it I will listen I'm happy
about that I know man tell all right
double 8 here are the real well no but
look that's but never underpaid move off
the web like Peter Parker went from
flying 30 spool at the private jets
getting charted this is my departure
trifle owes just the unjust just go
faster boom one money-making Mitch your
message tastes price low little heart
smart thank everyone for the attention
humble you don't forget my tummy hurts a
little bit we're okay basketball one
composes in their feeling that window be
rough I want people single kid tell them
not like
I would not let them score on it no
calling my phone I'm in Greek no
pressures that my neck is GSC I my feet
to my mom around the world my bucket
list is ever-changing women wet on
arrival we're here north or south to the
school regulations oh babe you look like
I'm Superman thank you thank you hi okay
let's do it
awesome scene a little bit how's the Q&A
set up I actually want to be from the
audience I want to go a lot of churning
there that's been presented for your
taxes because the harvest is watching
profit could be poppin magnet you can
feel like I staged now at a church here
in Ontario that's a stage hard serious
bigger they put me on I got you baby
every morning like I'm mark McGrath and
your body in my hands is my next collab
I'm texting back but not enough because
my life is poppin you have to do to do
things of the club I'm island-hopping
to use work about selling and marketing
wait two seconds if anything to learn in
any school ever thank you
when you give with expectation in return
[Applause]
insidious and too many people
interpreted as take Jeff chef ragussis
give gift Givaudan and so that's the
cadence you know especially we're asking
for something as big time as an
internship a trainer that becomes a
super competitive that's when you go to
do your homework of what the Baljit is
it's also that you can do a flip and
that would be cool on camera feels super
selfish and another exactly like you're
going to win twice say in I've been
thinking [ __ ] diplomas I got flax now
used to celebrate a thousand plays
looking back now I realize that the
journey is everything to me
yep see what you did going through it
there's like four battles no sir no sir
we'll get this it's awesome take care
man here's what I think is teachable I
think that most people that are not nice
to other people are broken inside and
are unhappy inside and I think through
you know real psychological work therapy
real self evaluation really hitting rock
bottom some shock to the system like
taking a year vacation or getting a
divorce or having that conversation with
their father about about that thing that
happened when they were 11 I mean
there's a million things that I do think
can unlock a dream I think they're the
hardest things in the world to do and I
don't take it lightly I've not been able
to do it so easily
so I don't think it's easy but I do
think it's achievable I think it takes
an enormous amount of self-reflection
acceptance and and humility on the part
of the person that's doing the actions
and it takes a complete reset of who
they are from a hardwiring standpoint
and so I would say yes but 99% of people
I don't think will pull it off and I
mean that by the way it's very hard the
practicality the grind the work the real
stuff the meat the potatoes
everybody wants the sizzle everybody
wants to write the article about the
billion-dollar kid the problem is
there's three of them right and and and
there's hundreds of thousands of
million-dollar kids and there's millions
of hundred thousand dollar kids the
problem is everybody's trying to map
their behavior to the three trillion
dollar kids and they'll fail and we need
to take that off the pedestal we need to
start putting the pedestal and putting
the people on there who are driving
practicality in reality because as I'm
talking to you I have enormous fear of
what happens when the economy gets
softer because it's been good for nine
years and that's why everybody's kind of
floating around and pretending the part
of founder those people can be working
at Bank of America and Toyota in five
minutes so they need to get practical
real fast but be careful with that I
would tell you my argument on this issue
is that every
has it's people that want an attention
every generation had it's people that
wanted money I think we're very lazy as
a society and throwing people into
groups I know plenty of lazy 40 year
olds and 50 year olds I know plenty of
40 and 50 year olds who always wanted
work/life balance and taking vacations I
know plenty of 40 and 50 year olds who
wanted one-on-one attention and I know
plenty of twenty and thirty year olds
who want the money so so I would say and
I know I can tell by your vibe you're
going to agree with I'm going to say
which is I spend zero time on the macro
of what's going on in the world of the
current conversation it is always one on
one meaning what does that person want
right now because guess what what Darach
wants right now and is 29 years old five
years old for zero you know what he
wants today this could be different in
seven years so like so like not only is
it one on one it's one on one with in a
moment Simone I'll tell you okay
for five minutes I know okay well you
know what's going on that remark like
what makes Ohio like I leave on the next
guy come on I know yeah cool
all right good I'll be with you in a few
minutes when your bangs ever come with
it oh yeah last time was easy it was
like going to a Knicks game
oh please go we need everyone
all right boom one second close all
ready to throw like oh you're wrong in
the interview we got that you got to do
that this again yeah of course it bran
bro we got this all right now we're
going to literally take 15 seconds okay
like but if you need to top out because
I know you got a plane to catch and I
don't I just walk people know they have
time
way too many fifty five year olds think
it's over especially cuz we live in this
tech world where it's all about the 20
and 30 year olds like never before and
we just have time I mean I think I said
this to you and I'll say it to all of
you I mean like when I look at all these
young faces like you know like [ __ ] I'm
41 years old and I feel like I'm seven
like I feel like I feel like I feel like
I'm just starting I'm like okay now the
foundation is you know like people are
33 and they have two kids and find
themselves
like [ __ ] what like your kind and and
we're in control
and I just want people realize they have
one life because that's practical that's
true
that's actually unless somebody listen
by the way if you can prove to me
otherwise I'll be really happy
get in here yes one second this man for
self are you can put it you've got to
put in the work so steady we're doing
video yeah cuz I know that you have a
Nemedia in the video hey Danny thank you
buddy
thank you thank you so much all right
okay fine here all right all right I
heard about hurry I'm gonna miss my
place when you're [ __ ] selfie let's go
yeah we're dropping them off around the
corner all got a good how are you good
to see you brother
how are you how are things that's been
cleaned in thanks very fun how you doing
really not you know the energy of stuff
like that is so over the top right yeah
I mean look in there good what's going
on come with me we're gonna do I know I
know Andy I know we were making a bunch
of different decisions but when it give
you my help otherwise can I help a lien
it away yeah connecting yeah yeah okay
Quincy right Thank You Susan er yes
that's good yeah look like Thank You
Casey yeah yeah yo I didn't want to
leave without saying goodbye
are you leaving yeah I missed my flight
um this is a good
prelude baby yeah Hamburg or something
we gotta figure out we will do how to go
out there the love of the crowd is you
know this you're the king of this I love
it I love people
I'm not the king of this going back to
New York City right now break a second
I'm literally gonna miss my flight but
be rocks head your backyard I'm like I
gotta get my pear so this here is a
letter gonna see brother day bye guys
bye thank you so much
all right I know my man I'm sorry for no
good reason tight with no good night
three we should be okay right we'll
check in right there customs it's in a
cup go see what happens I mean yeah I
mean I just think I can like I done
really well and I'm only 41 years old
and you know I am NOT going to be a Mark
Zuckerberg you know kind of marked you
then one big event tons of money and you
know I hope I hope I stay healthy and
like Elysees healthy and very frankly I
have a woody so safe out there anytime
anytime
[Music]
I think um I think it was a different
kind of vibe
mmm-hmm whatever whatever we have to do
to paint a different picture in your
mind then we'll hack at you no because
it's going well it really is I mean I
appreciate your aspiration but but I
can't let them come at the expense of
your mentality and that's good man by
the way I like the KPI the big the big
win from this is learning that the big
win of being in my inner circle is the
thing that I haven't brought up a lot
lately which is 99% of things don't
matter if we heated you not at the
expense of your yeah I mean if you out
pressure yourself so you have to be able
to achieve it like I have the biggest
ambitions of all time but I'm also
extremely comforted and accepting my
shortcomings and not everything's going
to work out perfectly
the ambition for perfection the quickest
way to not achieve perfection
aside from what it is yeah yeah Alan
California counting on my blessings only
24 with a multi-million dollar attention
off my catalog
that's because I'm a dawn like Tito cuz
I'm Han and I got more songs in the
Beatles oh that's a stretch and I guess
but you get the gist laughing at the
skeptics because I always knew I get the
twist
family knew in movies knew that's
finally about it whether you come in the
game too quickly you go out it darling
really bout [ __ ] y'all ain't got no
substance yeah I heard you little viral
song some fun dumb [ __ ] someone munch it
your sees little rapper you will fix the
world [ __ ] cuz we leave a new asset
don't hit my phones with can stupid [ __ ]
that's not why I gave you my number you
stupid [ __ ]
the leading block I don't have what I
want wonders 10 min to fact haters
grounded in doubt meanwhile I'm swimming
in cash I was never cool as y'all try to
link up now because my train left the
station but it's a brake truck now I
switch the South like I was dating by do
is common to hate on the truth I'm
father my name on the roof of hip hop
and breaking on through to the other
side like Jim Morrison because I think
Jim wondering if I drink more than him
scary thoughts I got the juice like
Barry Bonds I ain't trying to blend in
like white kids with berries on you take
it then these rappers who keeps on
acclaimed indie majors and Nexus
millions behind you you're not indie get
offended and I got you back hip hop
collar could you could told me that only
a hit
dog Hollis hot
what they pay me for the flows nowadays
we going to catch me sleeping ever again
three women three clothes nowadays all
we got is time so my time is my
investment I'm single so I save money
and live better yes
I need my plastic van telda all right
double-a underrated and overlooked yes
but never underpaid ruins off the web
like Peter Parker went from flying 30
who has the private jets getting charted
so just let it back into Jersey and
that's fun I was like claiming in New
York just little Jersey love Holland
Tunnel up in front of us I love that
place anyway but great speech this
morning in Canada hectic boom boom boom
boom boom a little more more MORE
casings nice fat spoke after me finally
getting his last name down the rock I'm
proud of myself
boy I'm bad at that anyway Casey was
amazing obviously always fun to be in
the presence of somebody who's got a
bigger social media Polly with you he
crushes and on YouTube doesn't sing its
own social bunch of people talking about
in quoting and I forgot and it was
reminding me which is when I invest in
this company I told them like the ideas
you know solid but very hard to execute
we'll see but I'm betting on the jockey
not the horse a lot of you have heard me
say that but it seems like this was a
successful investment of mine I invested
some six figures into Casey's company
and it returned when he sold it CNN and
it's only happened because of the jockey
and so more and more on my life I'm
paying attention to ideas are fine but
it's the people executing them that
really really really matter it's nice to
hear him say that I'm feeling that these
at the apex so I feel like I'm entering
the prime of my career as a jockey
I think these next 20 years are going to
be the best entrepreneur years of my
career I really do and if I stick at 16
what have you I'll be focusing on the
Jets and
and family stuff I could just see a
chain I could feel them in it I'm
excited about it and and that's humbling
to hear from the case thanks for that
Casey and thanks for all of these guys
attention had a lot of you say today
that many people said today multiple
people said today when I was given love
back and sticking around a selfie and
almost missed my flight I'm proud to be
giving you my attention this seems like
a lot of you're paying attention to what
uh what matters man so I'm grateful
insightful and appreciate it and hope
you are joining enjoying this journey as
much as I am that the journey is
everything the Hangul destination
managed Anya is everything looking back
I realized the journey is that we've
been a no destination man is johnny is
devil
[Music]